في خطر الذكاء الاصطناعي يهدد كتابها
وجديد سرعات ماس مكالمات صوتيه عبر تويتر
وترامب متهم بالتحرش بريء من الاغتصاب
اهلا بكم الى تفاعلكم
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم ازمه كبرى تواجهها 15 عاما على
اخر اضراب قام به كتابه 2007 وخلف خسائر
كبرى قدرت وقتها بملياريار دولار عاد
الكتاب الى الاضراب مره اخرى منذ ايام من
بعد فشل في التوصل الى نتائج مرضيه في
محادثاتهم مع شركات الانتاج العملاقه
والتحالف استوديوهات السينما والتلفزيون
11 الف كاتب وكاتبه اي ما يقارب
98% من اعضاء النقابه شاركوا في هذا
الاضراب وتوقفوا عن العمل وخرجوا في
تظاهرات كبرى في شوارع نيويورك وهوليوت
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
عما عن اسباب الادراك فكانت متنوعه من حيث
المطالب حيث طلب كتاب هوليود برفع اجورهم
وزياده نسبه ارباحهم الشركات الانتاج من
نتفليكس وامازون وغيرها الى ان الشركات
رفضت هذا المطلب بسبب تقلص الاعلانات ومن
المطالبات التي لفتت نظر هو خطر ذكاء
الاصطناعي
وهو البرنامج الذي باتي يعرف بقدرته على
كتابه نصوص القصيره وهو ما يهدد وظائفهم
حيث رفض الكتاب استخدام نصوصهم في تدريب
الذكاء الاصطناعي ورفضوا مراجعه ومعالجه
المسودات التي يكتبها الذكاء الاصطناعي
وطالبوا بالتوقف عن اللجوء للذكاء
الاصطناعي لكتابه نصوص والسيناريوهات
القصيره التي باتت تستهوي شركات الانتاج
كون هذه الطريقه تخفض عليهم التكاليف ساهم
الاضراب في تاخير عدد من الافلام
والمسلسلات المقرره عرضها قريبا بالاضافه
الى توقف عدد من البرامج الشهيره اما
البيت الابيض فكان قد اعلن ان الرئيس
الامريكي جو بايدن يامل توصل سريعا الى
اتفاق منصف بشان كتاب السيناريو المضربين
وذلك خوفا من تكبد المجال السمعي والبصري
خسائر بمليارات الدولارات كما حدث سابقا
على كل حول هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا من
القاهره الكاتب والسيناريس وليد خيري وليد
اهلا بكم معنا في تفاعلكم يبدو ان كتاب
هوليود يعني وبعد ازمه تقلص الدعايات لم
يكن ينقصهم سوى دخول برنامج الذكاء
الاصطناعي على الخط الى اي مدى اليوم
الذكاء الاصطناعي يهدده ويهدد عقول صناع
السينما هناك
اهلا بك سيدتي بالطبع هو يخطئ يهدد
البشريه كلها الذكاء الاصطناعي وصل في في
وقت وجيز
لمراحل المتقدمه في مراحل الابحاث في
مراحل
الاصوات في مراحل الان الكتابه اعتقد ان
المطالب التي تقدم بها كتاب السنوي
الامريكان ليست مطالب تخصهم وحدهم ولكنها
تخص الكتاب في العالم لانه الخطر القادم
لا محاله فكره
الطرح الذي طرحوه بانه امتنعوا عن تبييض
المستودات التي قام بها الذكاء الاصطناعي
في فن كتابه السيناريو او تقديم سنوياتهم
الخاصه
ليستعين بها الذكاء الاصطناعي مستقبلا في
في عمليه كتابه الثانوي اعتقد هذه لابد ان
تكون هناك قوانين حازمه لانه شئنا ام
ابينا اذ لم يكن هنا قوانين فهذا الامر
سنصبح كل الكتاب في العالم وليس في امريكا
فقط
سيصبحون
جلوس في المنازل لا يعملون لان الذكاء
الاصطناعي سيوفر لكل الاستديوهات في
العالم
بتكلفه اقل بالطبع سنوات محبوكه بشكل جيد
وهذا خطر كبير جدا على كل مجالات البشريه
يعني الذكاء الاصطناعي ثوره كبيره جدا طيب
علينا ان نتعامل معاها
بوجه به استفاده دون ضرر طيب وليد المعروف
ببرنامج الذكاء الاصطناعي انه ينتج محتواه
انطلاقا من تغذيته بشريا بالبيانات اليوم
عندما يهدد كتاب هوليود بعدم معالجه
النصوص في هذا البرنامج الى مدى يهدد
فعاليه في هذا الاطار في المجال تحديده
بالضبط هذا حقنا ككتاب هذا حق اصيل لانه
او او يكون هناك اتفاقيات مسبقه ان يكون
هناك فكره الكاتب الاصيل يعني او الكاتب
الاصلي يعني اذا انا مديت مثلا الذكاء
الاصطناعي تنسب هذه الاعمال اللي هي ككاتب
اصلي ان هذه مستقاه او ماخوذه من الكاتب
الاصلي الذي مد الذكاء الاصطناعي بهذه
السنوات او هذه التويستات او هذه الحبكات
فاعتقد هذه مساله غايه في الخطوره وعلينا
كل كتاب في العالم ان نقف مساندين للكتاب
الامريكان لانهم يطالبون بثلاث مطالب
مشروعه بنسبه من بنسبه من
بنسبه في الانتاج بمعنى انني كاتب بالاساس
العمليه الابداعيه تقوم بدايه من الكاتب
والكاتب ياخذ اجواء فقط بينما الكتابه
لسنوات طويله على شركات الانتاج ولا
استوديوهات مكاسب من انواع شتى العمل
الفني لسنوات طويله لشركات الطيران لمنصات
الرقميه الجديده بتدفقيه للاستوديوهات
بشكل اسوه بالاغاني والالحان الموسيقيه
يعني من حق الكتاب ان يحافظوا على حقوقهم
بشكل اصيل ودائم طيب وليد بعد شهرين من
اطلاق هذا البرنامج برنامج الاصطناعي
استخدموا 100 مليون مستخدم نشط خلال شهر
واحد الى ان مدى هذا البرنامج اليوم يهدد
كل السيناريوهات ام فقط السيناريوهات
القصيره يعني المواد المكتوبه بشكل قصير
لا طبعا في خلال شهرين حصل هذا التطاول
مفزع فانا لست ضده وبالتالي هذه حتمات
تاريخيه لكن نريد قوانين
تؤسس لهذا يعني لهذا الغول الجديد هذا غول
قد غول قد نستطيع ان نستفيد منه وقد
يستطيع ان يدور الجميع وليس في الكتابه
فقط لك ان تتخيلي ان العالم قريبا سيجلس
الجميع في منازلهم في كل المهن حتى حتى
مهنتك سيدتي نحن معرضون تماما كلنا ان
نجلس في البيوت لان الذكاء الاصطناعي
سيقوم باضواء الجميع
فانا اعتقد هذه وقفه مهمه جدا جدا لكل
الصناع وليس حتى نفهم الموضوع اكثر يعني
76% من مستخدمي تشارجي بيتي يقولون ان
مواده المكتوبه عاليه الجوده يعني يعني
قيموها بشكل ملفت جدا هل بامكان هذا
البرنامج ان يكتب افلام سيناريوهات طبعا
لافلام طويله لمسلسلات
لازم تدخل بشري نعم بالطبع الفكر نعم
يستطيع جدا لنا المساله حتى خاصه في
امريكا يعني امريكا حتى لها علاقه
بالسياره مختلفه عن السينما الاوروبيه
مثلا امريكا بتعتمد على فكره القوانين في
الكتابه السيناريو امريكا تتعامل مع
السيناريو وكانه كانه نص كانه مساله
حسابيه قوانين في بعد عشر دقائق يحدث كذا
بعد كذا ثم الكول ثم افضى الكول يعني
بتتعمل حتى من كان بالذات بيتعاملوا مع
السيناوي بشكل احترافي يبدو كانه مباراه
كانه حزب الرياضيه فبالتالي الذكاء
الاصطناعي اذا تم امداد بكل هذه المواد
يستطيع ان ينتج الاف وخاصه وخاصه في انواع
السنوات التي تعتمد على التويستات
والحبكات وعلى المفاجات والاثاره اعتقد
سيكون متفوقا بشكل كبير حتى على الجانب
البشري بالنهايه شكرا جزيلا لك من القاهره
حدثنا الكاتب والسيناريست وليد خيري شكرا
وليد
اهلا بكم من جديد يوما بعد يوم تسعى
المنصات على اختلاف انواعها واسمائها الى
تطوير مزاياها وخدماتها للمستخدمين تويتر
من بين تلك التطبيقات التي يسعى ايلون
ماسك لتطويره منذ بدايه استحواذه عليه
فبعد ان اعلن امس عن البدء في اكبر عمليه
لحذف حسابات المستخدمين غير ناشطين وعن
دعمه لصانع محتوى فجاه ماسك متابعيه
باضافه ميزه الرسائل المشفره والمكالمات
عبر تويتر وقال في تغريد قريبا ستتوفر
المحادثات الصوتيه وعبر الفيديو في حسابك
مع اي شخص في هذا العالم وعلى هذه المنصه
وبالتالي سيمكنك التحدث الى الناس في اي
مكان دون ان تعطيهم رقم هاتفك وستنطلق
خدمه الرسائل المشفره غدا يمكن ان يكون
هذا تحديد ضمن التحديث الذي اعلنا عنه
العام الماضي تويتر تطبيق كل شيء والذي
قال انه سيوفر مزايا مثل الرسائل المباشره
المش فره والتغريدات الطويله وخدمات
المدفوعات وبالتالي يمكن ان يكون تويتر
منافسا لغيره من التطبيقات التي تستعمل
ذات الميزات مثل واتساب والذي قال عنه
ماسك لانه يمكن او لا يمكن الوثوق به ردا
على تغريده لاحد مهندس تويتر كتب فيها ان
واتساب كان يستخدم الميكروفون في الخلفيه
بين مكانه نائما
ما تحدث به ايلون ماسك هو مهندس تويتر لم
يمر مرور الكرام عند شركه واتساب التي
نشرت بيانا رسميا قالت فيه انها كانت على
اتصال بمهندس تويتر والذي نشر مشكله في
هاتفه بالواتساب قالت انها تعتقد انما حصل
هو خطا في نظام التشغيل اندرويد يؤدي الى
خطا في لوحه بيانات الخصوصيه الخاصه بهم
وانهم قاموا بالطلب من شركه جوجل بالتحقيق
فيها ومعالجتها اكدت ان اتصالات واتساب
محميه عن طريق التشفير ولا يمكن سماعها
حتى من الشركات نفسها ولابد من الذكرى ان
واتساب ايضا كشف عن تطويره ميزه جديده
تتيح لمستخدمه تعديل الرساله بعد ارسالها
بشرط ان يتم التعديل خلال خمسه عشره دقيقه
وسيتم كتابه ان رساله تم تعديلها بجانبها
فبدلا من ان يقوم الشخص بحذف الرساله
بالكامل او ارسال رساله اخرى يقوم
بتعديلها فقط بدات الميزه التجريبيه ظهور
على واتساب ويب ورصدها عدد كبير من
مستخدمي التطبيق مؤخرا قام باطلاق ميزه
تشغيل حساب واتساب على اكثر من جهاز وفي
وقت واحد على كل عن جديد
من الرياض عبد الله السبع محرش شؤون
التقنيه في عربيه عبد الله حياك اهلا بك
معنا في تفاعلكم من خدمه الرسائل المشفره
الى خدمه المكالمات الصوتيه ومحادثات
الفيديو الى اي مدى بالفعل تويتر يحتاج
اليوم الى هذه الميزات
[موسيقى]
تويتر حاليا قاعد يتحول من منصه التواصل
الاجتماعي الى شيء اخر لا تستغربون خلال
السنه القادمه يكون موجود في تويتر عملات
رقميه قادر انك تدفع من خلال تويتر لاي
عبد الله فقط يركز على هذه الميزه مختلفه
طيب معاك نستغل وجودك معانا نركز على هذه
الميزه ميزه المكالمات الصوتيه والمحادثات
الفيديو البعض من مستخدمي تويتر وهي منصه
تعتبر اكثر نخبويه اكثر كازا مقارنه بباقي
المنصات كسناب شات او انستجرام اعتبروها
يعني خرق للخصوصيه ان يقوم اي شخص في هذا
العالم من دون ان يكون له رقم او لديه رقم
تليفونك ان يتصل فيك ويحادثك لو نتحدث عن
اليه عمل هذه الميزه في تطبيق خاص تويتر
ما راح يكون اي شخص في العالم قادر يتواصل
معاك لا راح تكون موجوده داخل الرسائل
الخاصه انت اذا سمحت للناس انك تتواصل
معاك في الرسائل الخاصه راح يكون بامكانهم
انهم يتواصلون معك زي فكره سناب شات
بالضبط الان في سناب شات اي شخص يتواصل
معك اذا كان هو موجود عندك في الرسائل
الخاصه بالسناب شات قادر يتواصل معك فهذه
هي راح تكون نفس الطريقه اي شخص انت
سامحنا انه يتواصل معاك في تويتر عن طريق
الرسائل الخاصه راح يكون عنده امكانيه انه
يدخل عليك ويتواصل معاك عن طريق الاتصال
فالفكره ما فيها مشاكل تهدد خصوصيه
المستخدمين انما هي فكره معمول فيها في كل
المنصات طيب اذا هي معمول فيها في سناب
شات اذا هي معمول فيها في الفيسبوك اذا هي
معمول فيها في انستجرام ليه ما فيها مشاكل
تخصوصيه يوم عملت فيها تويتر صار فيها
مشاكل خصوصيه الامر جدا سلس بسيط خصيه
المستخدم لا زالت في امان ما راح يكون في
اي مشاكل انما هي ميزه جديده متاحه
للمستخدمين انت حابب تستفيد منها وتجربها
جربها انا من الناس مثلا الى الان ما
استفدت من خدمه الاتصال الفيديو او الصوتي
في انستجرام لان ما عندي ناس كثير في
الرسائل الخاصه وانا استخدمها فلذلك اتوقع
للامر راح يكون عندي سيان في تويتر لكن هل
المستخدمين البقيه راح يستخدمون المنصه
ويعتمدون عليها في الاتصال والتواصل ممكن
ذلك خاصه انه راح تساهم في توسع المنصه
بشكل اكبر في بعض الدول طيب عبد الله يعني
الملفت انه في الوقت الذي يسعى فيه ماسك
لاستخدام نفس ميزات واتساب يقوم في الوقت
ذاته بانتقاد واتساب وميزاته ويقول انه
تطبيق غير موثوق هل يندرج ذلك في اطار
المنافسه
طبيعي جدا واتساب قاعد يتحول حاليا من
تطبيق تواصل بين المستخدمين الى منصه
اجتماعيه واتساب لو تحول الى منصه
اجتماعيه راح يهدد كل منصات التواصل
الاجتماعيه المختلفه لذلك الفيسبوك شرط
التطبيق بمليارات الدولارات الواتساب عنده
شعبيه جدا كبيره وعنده قدره انه في يوم
وليله يتحول من منصه عاديه الى المنصه
اللي يستهدف يعني ايلون ماسك عندها هدف
وجول انه يتحول الى تطبيق يشبه تطبيق وي
شات الصيني الواتساب عند القدره انه يوصل
لهذا الموضوع اسرع من التويتر لو طبق هذا
الموضوع لكنه المنافسه بين الشركات من
صالح المستخدمين في النهايه راح يشوف
مميزات جدا كثيره خلال السنوات القادمه
يسرع من وتيره التطوير ويسرع من تبني
الخدمات الجديده اللي يحتاجونهم
المستخدمين السؤال عبد الله يعني من الدفع
مقابل التوثيق الى اليوم نشوف رسائل مشفره
مكالمات ومحادثات فيديو ما الصراعات
المتوقعه من ترامب في تويتر كخبير في هذا
الشهر
متوقع انه يدخل
واضح ان التاثير السياسي
انا متاكد انه راح يكون في صراعات ما بين
تويتر وانستجرام خلال السته شهور القادمه
خاصه تويتر قاعد تغير من طريقه تقديم
المحتوى داخل المنصه قاعد تدعم المستخدم
بشكل جدا كبير طبعا في صراع واضح حاليا مع
تيك توك لكنه الصراع هذا على قولتهم هادئ
جدا بسيط جدا لان احتمال يكون في حجب لتيك
توك في في الاشهر القادمه لذلك لو تم حجم
تيك توك في امريكا او اي دوله اخرى راح
يتوجه للمستخدمين المنصات البديله وتويتر
راح تكون ضمن هذه المنصات خاصه مع دعم
مميزات مختلفه يحتاجونها المستخدمين
بانتظار سرعات ترامب في التروس سوشيال هذه
المره شكرا لك عبد الله السبع محرر الشؤون
التقنيه عربيه حدثنا شكرا لك
[موسيقى]
امرت هيئه المحلفين في نيويورك الرئيس
الامريكيه السابق دونالد ترامب بدفع غرامه
قدرها خمسه ملايين دولار الكاتبه
الامريكيه كارول التي اتهمته في وقت سابق
بضربها واغتصابها في متجر للملابس
والتشهيري بها فبعد اسبوعين من جلسات
الاستماع لكارول ولشهود خرجت كارول من
المحكمه مبتسمه بعد ان اعلنت هيئه
المحلفين عن براءه ترامب من قضيه الاغتصاب
التي اتهمته بها كارول كون الهيئه لم تجد
اي دليل لواقعه الاغتصاب لكنها امرت ترامب
بدفعه لغرامه قدرها خمسه ملايين دولار
للاعتداء عليها بالضرب والتحرش بها
والتشهير وصفه لها بانها كاذبه طبعا ترامب
لم يلتزم بالصمت وكعادته كتب على منصه
وقال انه لا يعرف من هي هذه المراه وان
هذا الحكم ازعاج بالنسبه له عاد ترامبو
نشر منشورا اخر قال فيه ان الحكمه غير
عادل ولابد مشاهدينا ان نذكر ان الترام
قال سابقا بان هيئه المحلفين لم تسم ح له
بالدفاع عن نفسه بالاتهامات الكاذبه
لكارول على الرغم من انه مرشح سياسي حالي
وقال انه مهما كانت النتيجه سيستانف
الاسكاتا غير الدستوري له
[موسيقى]
يبدو ان الكاتبه الامريكيه كوريرتشينز لم
تتمكن من اخفاء اثار جريمتها على الرغم من
تاليفها كتابا كاملا ينطلق من تجربتها
الشخصيه في فقدان زوجها ويصف حاله الحزن
والحداد بعد وفاته فهي تواجه الان تومه
قتل زوجها
الذي عثر عليه بيتا في غرفتهما في ولايه
يوتا في شهر مارس الماضي قالت الزوجه
حينها انها كانت تعد شرابا لزوجها ووجدته
ميتا في غرفتهما اظهرا تشريح الجثه ان
الرجل مات بسبب جرعه زائده في الفينتانيل
وهي ماده افيونيه صناعيه قويه كان الرجل
قد ابتلع منها خمسه اضعاف الجرعه القاتله
التي اودت بحياته تم القبض على الزوجه من
قبل شرطه ولايه يوتا بتهمه القتل العمل
وحيازه عقار ممنوع في منزلها بعد تشريح
جثه زوجها خلص المحققون الى ان زوجته طلبت
من احد معارفها تزويدها
قويه للالم وحصلت منه على ثلاثين حبه من
عقار الذي تانه بعد ان صممت زوجها قامت
بتاليف كتاب للاطفال بعنوان هل انت معي
يتكلم عن قصه الطفل فقد والده لكن يتم
تذكيره بانه لا يزال موجودا في كل مكان
حوله قالت انها استلهمت فكره الكتاب من
تجربتها مع اطفالها الثلاثه والذين فقدوا
والدهم
بهذا الخبر مشاهدينا وصلنا الى ختام حلقه
تفاعلكم اليوم شكرا لكم على كرم المتابعه
في امان الله
[موسيقى]